headline in New York Post
gay thruppel hopes to be second in U.S
to officially be parents so these are
three guys who like each other more than
guys who are supposed to like each other
in a different way than guys are
supposed to like each other and they're
pretending that they're married and now
they're adopting a child right now go to
puretalk.com use promo code Knowles tax
season is here you want to make your
accountant happy I got one super easy
way to do it switch to pure talk instead
of paying a fortune to Verizon ATT or
T-Mobile cut your bill in half with pure
talk Pure Talk offers unlimited talk
text and plenty of data starting at just
30 bucks a month and saving the average
family over 900 a year a lot of people
think the bigger the provider the better
the service let me fill you in on a
little secret Pure Talk uses the same
network not saying a comparable Network
I'm saying the exact same network for
less there's no contract no hidden fees
no hassle switch over to Pure Talk in as
little as 10 minutes while keeping your
phone your phone number they're us-based
customer service team
worth the switch just for the us-based
customer service team make that switch
really really easy pure talk so sure
you're gonna love the service they're
backing it up with a 100 money back
guarantee your first month is guaranteed
risk free go to puretalk.com enter promo
code knows to save 50 off your first
month puretalk.com promo code Knowles
Pure Talk is simply smarter Wireless the
New York Post is known for some pretty
crazy headlines
craziest part of this headline though
it's not the gay throuple part it's not
the idea that they're adopting it's that
they're not even the first to do it this
has already happened once before now
there's another Trio of men who want to
adopt a little child
from the article quote
Tegan is going to love having three dads
she will always have so much love
we would let them know Love Is Love from
a mother or a father and them here one
of these men is referring to them in the
singular
they're saying the daughter instead of
saying let her know saying let them know
that Love Is Love from a mother or a
father
Ben said one of the fathers according to
the independent
so that sounds really nice that's a nice
happy liberal line look she's gonna have
so much love we're gonna let her know
that Love Is Love from a mother or a
father but what's the translation of
that the translation of that sentence is
mothers aren't important
mothers don't matter at all
baby doesn't need a mother forget about
a baby doesn't need a mother sometimes
tragedies happen mothers die okay
mothers don't matter
mothers don't add anything to raising a
child that's what that means
and that is the view that is now popular
in Liberal circles and it's the view
reflected in our law
the moment that any
municipality in this country
permitted
gay adoption
I'll go further back the moment that any
municipality in this country permitted
single mother adoption
or single a single father adoption a
thing I hope not but probably it is
these days the moment that the moment
that our law said that marriage is
either the union of a man and a woman or
the union of two men or the union of two
women the moment that the law said those
things
the law said mothers don't matter or
conversely fathers don't matter
that's fine you know there's no there's
no advantage to having a mother or a
father
it's just whatever whatever adults want
to do to satisfy their sexual appetites
and Fantasies that's all that matters
and then if they want a kid because they
have a natural longing to have a kid
well that's fine and if they're in a
disordered sort of situation well you
know
they're just that's just love is love
is love wouldn't it be good if the kid
had a mother though don't you think not
let's shhh Love Is Love
Love Is Love that's what that means The
Story Goes On
from one of the fellas
to know that I'm making a path for other
relationships that look like mine feels
good it reminds me of the early days
when I was fighting for legal rights to
get married to a man or two lesbians to
marry
this is a really important sentence
because he's wrong about the idea that
two men can marry each other or the two
women can marry each other that's not
possible there's no no
hate on the fellas you know I got plenty
of friends who have all sorts of uh
Divergent views of sex and gender okay
I'm from New York I went to a very gay
University I lived in La I have a
disproportionate number of friends who
are have gone down these paths and have
these kinds of views okay and there's no
animus toward anybody at all it's simply
a fact of the meaning of the word
marriage that if marriage is to have any
meaning at all it has to involve sexual
difference
the moment you take that away you take
all the boundaries off of marriage and
very quickly thereafter you end up with
a throuple all the conservatives who
said well if we're going to redefine
marriage to take away sexual difference
why won't we have polygamy soon
and what did the lib say they said
that's a crazy ridiculous slippery slope
stupid argument well here we are it's
not
marriage wasn't redefined all that long
ago and now we've got not that not the
first thrupple to adopt children but the
second and you're gonna see the third
and the fourth and the fifth and the
sixth
the point that he makes here though is
actually a very good point one of these
fellas he says this reminds me of the
early days when I was fighting for legal
rights to redefine all these things and
I know that I'm making a path for other
relationships that look like mine that's
true
if we tolerate this as a matter of
culture and law we're gonna get more of
it
one of the big mistakes that the right
has made in recent decades is we've
bought into some kind of magical
thinking
According to which if the government
Outlaws something you don't necessarily
get less of it
and if the government encourages
something you don't necessarily get more
of it you see this especially in Shallow
debates over drugs
every every pot head sophomore in
college will say hey man you know what I
I think we should legalize all the drugs
because the thing is man if you legalize
the drugs you're going to get less of
the drugs now man because it's illegal
everyone's doing it more but if you make
it legal man you probably get a lot less
of it you know what I mean man
that's what they say and that has never
been true anywhere ever in human history
and it's just a basic fact of economics
and human life if you incentivize
something you get more of it if you
disincentivize something you get less of
it and right now our society
has laid all of the groundwork to
incentivize
thruples
and thruples adopting poor little kids
who will be intentionally deprived of a
mother or of a father
and that's wrong that's very wrong and
if we're gonna if we all know that this
is wrong as we all do
then we have to ask well why is it wrong
and if we want to correct that wrong
we're going to have to go back and fix
some of the errors that we've made in
recent years it's music Monday baby we
got to get to it the rest of the show
continues now you don't want to miss it
become a member and use code Knowles at
checkout for two months free on all
annual plans dailywire.com Knowles code
Knowles
[Music]
foreign